Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Jesús Onieva Palomar
Estás en la cola del
supermercado cuando, oh, oh,
alguien estornuda sobre ti.
El virus de la gripe
entra a los pulmones
y llega a una célula
de la pared respiratoria.
Todo ser del planeta
está hecho de células,
desde las bacterias unicelulares
hasta la gigante ballena azul, o tú.
Cada célula está rodeada
de una membrana celular,
una capa flexible compuesta
por grasas y proteínas,
que rodean y protegen
los componentes internos.
Es semipermeable,
o sea, deja entrar
y salir ciertas cosas
pero bloquea otras.
La membrana está cubierta
por pequeños salientes,
que tienen funciones
como que las células se adhieran
o unirse a los nutrientes necesarios.
Las animales y vegetales
tienen membranas.
Las vegetales tienen pared celular,
formada por celulosa rígida
que le da estructura a la planta.
La célula del virus que entra
a los pulmones es astuta.
Fingiendo ser amiga,
se une a un saliente
de la membrana celular,
atravesándola y llegando a la célula.
Al entrar el virus,
la célula reconoce su error.
¡Entró un enemigo!
También hay unas enzimas
que reducen el virus a pedazos.
Luego envían uno de los pedazos
por la membrana,
y advierten a las células vecinas
sobre el invasor.
Una célula vecina lo ve
y de inmediato entra en acción.
Tiene que hacer anticuerpos,
proteínas que acabarán
con el virus invasor.
Este proceso empieza en el núcleo.
El núcleo contiene nuestro ADN,
que le dice a las
células cómo hacer todo
lo necesario para que
el cuerpo funcione.
Una parte de nuestro ADN
contiene instrucciones
que indican a las células
cómo crear anticuerpos.
Las enzimas encuentran
la sección correcta de ADN
y copian estas instrucciones,
es el ARN mensajero.
El ARN mensajero sale del núcleo
para ejecutar sus órdenes.
El ARN mensajero va hasta un ribosoma.
Puede haber 10 millones de ribosomas
en una célula humana,
todos ellos en forma de lazo,
formando el retículo endoplasmático.
Este ribosoma lee las
instrucciones del núcleo.
Toma aminoácidos
y los une uno a uno
creando un anticuerpo
que combatirá al virus.
Pero antes de eso,
el anticuerpo tiene
que salir de la célula.
El anticuerpo se dirige
al aparato de Golgi.
Aquí lo preparan
para que salga de la célula.
Cubierto por una burbuja
igual a la membrana celular.
El aparato de Golgi también
le da instrucciones al anticuerpo
para que llegue al borde de la célula.
Una vez allí,
la burbuja se fusiona
con la membrana celular.
La célula expulsa al anticuerpo,
y se dirige a localizar al virus.
Se eliminan los restos de burbuja
por los lisosomas
y sus piezas se reciclan una y otra vez.
¿De dónde se obtiene
la energía para hacer esto?
Ese es el papel de la mitocondria.
Para producir energía, toma oxígeno,
por esta sola razón respiramos,
y le añade electrones de la comida
para formar moléculas de agua.
Este proceso crea
una molécula de energía
llamada ATP que la célula
distribuye por sus componentes.
Las células vegetales crean
la energía de otra forma
Tienen cloroplastos
que combinan CO2 y agua
con la energía lumínica del sol
para crear oxígeno y azúcar,
una forma de energía química.
Todas las partes trabajan juntas
para que las cosas funcionen bien
y todas las células hacen lo mismo
para que no haya problemas.
Son un montón de células.
Los científicos estiman que hay
unos 37 billones de células.